So did chest x-ray results wonder if you can go over that I saw a new occupational therapist yesterday that has advanced trading in a demon yesterday
I was doing borax oil compresses on legs and the ROT compresses on liver and I felt like I was going to have a heart attack by
Right chest hurt where the cancer started where the metastasis really started or maybe
well underneath where the cancer started in your breast I mean I have noticed this sometimes when doing my lymphatic exercises too my
therapist told me my body was trying but can't get rid of the fluid that fast to slow down after getting about 10 pounds in a
couple weeks my oncologist is a bit concerned okay stop right there a second so the pain that you're getting in your
feel like you're a heart attack because of the x-ray so the x-ray not because of the x-ray but what the x-ray revealed the x-ray revealed fluid in your lungs your
medial style area around your heart so it was obliterated the the border of your heart so when a radiologist looks at x-ray see border a border of your
heart where the the heart cavity is and a border of your lungs and when that border is obliterated that tells us that there's fluid there obliterating that border so you
can't see a nice clean border of a lung border or a liver border or a heart border so when there's the borders obliterated it's showing that there's
fluid there and if there's fluid there it can compress the heart in a kid put pressure on the heart and it could damage the heart worst-case scenario so you want to make sure that you if the if that is the
sighties fluid there that you get that fluid drained that can make you feel a hundred times better now the 10 pounds you gained certainly isn't all in your
lung so obviously there's fluid in your legs and things like that as well remember when you are getting your lymph pumped back into your try to get the fluid out of your tissues where is it
going it's going into the lymph vessels where is that going that's going into your into your into your venous system your veins and then where is that going that's ultimately going
through your liver and hopefully that in your kidneys and hopefully you're getting rid of it but if your kidneys and liver are overwhelmed then you're not going to be able to get rid of it
as fast so make sure make sure make sure just as we talk about in the the 7 phases of detoxification we could call we could have phases of lymphatic detoxification as well that fluid has to be able to get out through the
liver downstream from the tissues so make sure you're supporting your liver put a hot pass pack over your liver do castor oil packs over your liver do coffee animals that's going to be one of the best things you could do to get
the lymphatic system going or coffee animals helping the bad existing there helping your liver helping your parasympathetics and that will help your lymphatic systems another thing I noticed when I gave myself the hellabora shot that's the certain type of
mistletoe three quarters the dose I had the same chest pain that's because the mistletoe causing an inflammatory reaction it's a whole purpose of this.
This is supposed to reduce the inflammation or the hellaborus does help reduce the inflammation compared to the other mistletoe but you're getting inflammation from it it's totally because of inflammation not sure if the adema is from the chemo pill the radiation hellaborus or combination of all.
A college just doesn't believe it's from the chemo of course can you test for hellaborus I can so I can test if I think that is not going to be perfect but I could do cheap swap test to see if it's from that this is getting so confusing yeah you can just do a process of elimination kind of like a food elimination or hey I'm going to stay off the hellaborus for a period of time what does that change your only changing one thing what is it change in your symptoms.
um oh you said it right here probably just continue the mistletoe for a few weeks I don't know I think that would be a good idea instead of testing I would just stop it for a period of time and you'll know right away if there's if there's a change you'll let it.
You know the truth is too with any any of these type of things you could have a sensitivity to these things and it's reacting at a totally different level so that's a possibility too.